bunny ears the classic photo bomb pose
of two fingers stretched out like rapid
ears behind another person's head has
been a popular prank for decades but it
has a darker history also known as
cuckolds horns it goes back to the
Middle Ages
where the gesture was used to mock and
shame a man whose wife had cheated on
him cuckolds were sometimes made to wear
antlers on their heads it's also said
the gesture symbolized asses ears a
common insult in medieval times the word
cuckold comes from the French word for
cuckoo a reference to that birds habit
of laying its eggs in another bird's
nest the cuckold was a figure of fun in
the works of Chaucer and Shakespeare and
he was still being mocked even in
Victorian times we don't know who the
first person was to make the bunny ears
joke in a photo perhaps it began around
the 1950s when people started taking
photos of friends and family but in any
case the idea caught on and spread in
Italy the gesture is made using the
index and little finger and is known as
the devil's horn but the effect is the
same now it's a common feature of selfie
culture around the world but watch out
because you could be the bunny
[Music]